Okay.
Mm.
You've got a feel for
variables versus constants,
predicates versus subjects,
the quantifiers, no.
Summit all and taking
advantage of variable.
Send more scope to translate everyday
phrases into logic. If that's not true,
please go back and watch the
last three videos in this series.
It's time to move on to
a logical operators or
connectives logical connectives.
Let's build our sentences out a bit more.
To do that,
let's start with the logical connectives
add add or we can join two symbols with
Ad.
The conjunction can come between two
statements like she saw Bob and the house
is red or this is a
fish and fish can swim.
The conjunction might come between
two variables like x and y,
but and has less obvious applications.
If we want to say that
Bob is a good person,
we can break that sentence into
Bobby's human and Bob is good.
We can render some good person.
As for some x,
x is human and x is good
like many operators and may
be represented by different
symbols and different texts. For now,
stick with one and learn others as needed.
Also, let me mention that the meaning
of this logical and has pretty strong,
it asserts both things being joined,
so it's vanilla and chocolate means
that it's both vanilla and chocolate.
It's not the week and have you can choose
between vanilla and chocolate where
you actually mean or speaking of or
we can join sentences with or as well.
This disjunction might come
between two statements like p or Q,
like this is vanilla or this is chocolate,
but we can also use it
with variables x or y.
So everything is vanilla or chocolate
means that all x's are vanilla chocolate
or both? Both, yes, this
or is called inclusive.
So when you're joining two things with
the logical or realize that you're saying
the first thing,
the second thing or both of them,
if you want to rule out
the option of both of them,
you have to use what's called an exclusive
or it's vanilla or it's chocolate,
but it's not chocolate plus vanilla.
These ants and ores bringing up a topic I,
I brought up before the
scope of a quantifier.
Look at what happens when two
predicates are in a quantify or scope.
It applies to both of them.
For all x,
x is human and x can swim
just means everybody can swim.
For some x,
x is dirty or x is cluttered.
Something is dirty or cluttered.
Where you're saying that
this thing may be dirty,
cluttered or both dirty and
cluttered. Last, for some x,
x is not dirty or x is not
cluttered with an exclusive or
what happens when you negate to symbols
joined by an or or like not chocolate or
vanilla.
A set of rules known as Dimauro Gins.
Laws will help you deal with those cases.
If you want to say not chocolate and
vanilla, you'll rep represent the phrases,
not chocolate or vanilla.
On the flip side, you,
when you want to say not
chocolate or vanilla,
this comes out as not vanilla
and chocolate in logic,
not chocolate or vanilla is treated the
same as not chocolate and not vanilla.
Well not chocolate and vanilla is treated
like not chocolate or not vanilla.
Before moving onto the rest
of the connectives here,
a few phrases to translate use and or
or that's either and or or for each
statement
onto some new stuff. You're probably
already familiar with the equals symbol.
As you'd expect.
This indicates a logical equivalents
like some x is equal to some why.
Nothing new here,
so let's move on.
Consider sentences where you
say that if one thing is true,
then something else follows this.
If then construction is
very important in logic.
We'll use it to structure even very
basic statements where it's hidden in
ordinary language. Let's take the
statement. English is a language. No.
If then there,
the logic for this simple sentence is
actually for all x. If x is English,
then x is a language.
We can translate it this way where
the horse shoe symbol is the if then
conditional.
Take another sentence.
This time everybody swims in logic.
That's for all eggs.
If x is human,
the next swims,
there are other popular symbols for
this conditional like the left to right
Arrow,
like the versions of ads and knots.
There are different ways of writing
the same symbol. The logic is the same.
There's another type of conditional
called the bike conditional.
The meaning here is quite different.
It's if and only if,
let's take the sentence
only water is refreshing.
The sentence means for all x.
X is refreshing if and only if x is water
ratchet this up one level.
It's only edible if it's good food.
Here we mean for all x.
X is edible.
If and only if x is good and x is food,
notice that this if and
only if is really strong.
What's refreshing has to be water and
what's water has to be refreshing.
Likewise,
what's good food has to be edible and
what's edible has to be good food.
Next one, when you're drawing
a conclusion in language,
you often use the word therefore,
this therefore indicates that whatever
follows is implied by whatever came
before. You can show this in logic with
a triple dot before your conclusion.
Let's say you propose a simple line
reasoning like everybody knows something.
John Somebody so he knows something.
You're probably getting used to
translations into logic by now,
so I'll let you figure those phrases out.
The first one that's right for
all x for some y. If x is human,
the next knows why.
That's everybody knows something.
Your next line is simple.
John is human and the last therefore
for some why Joe and John knows why.
That's just about all the basic stuff
you need to begin uncovering the logic
behind everyday language.
Of course there are other logics that
expand the use of formal logic and give it
a variety of applications.
Let's take a look at one basic example
of such a logic called modal logic.
Modal logic allows you to incorporate
modals into the formal structure.
I briefly explored modal verbs in the
lessons on morphology or the grammar of
words and language.
Examples of modal verbs in English.
Our can May and must the basic modal
symbols in Mount Modal logic are it is
necessary and it is possible.
Okay.
For example,
think of a statement p,
take this as dogs read books.
If we say that it is necessary
that p this means it is necessary.
That dog's read books.
We can also say that dogs can read books.
It is not necessary that everyone
read books and dogs cannot read books.
Notice that when we say something
like can or it is possible,
that leaves a lot of room to discuss
the probability of that possibility,
which is one of those topics
I'll tackle in the next video.
I know I've thrown a lot out at you,
but I'm fairly sure you are already
getting a feel for how this kind of logic
really gets down to the structure
of thoughts expressed in language.
So let's move on to do a few translations.
Pause the video whenever
you need some time to think.
No,
that was fun.
Wasn't it all wrapped up these lessons
next time with the discussion of how to
represent members of a set and express
the language of probability in logic
until next time,
keep practicing.
Yeah.